you can see his creativity off the  dribble  i mean he's a completely different  player tonight love davis a couple  plays in a row were pretty sensational  the love to a.d from lebron and then  lebron saves it blindly and they dodge a  bullet because they missed the shot the  lakers go down and get buckled  [Applause]  [Music]  rocket teams feel real real good about  themselves chasing lebron saves it but  now it's a three on one reeves tried to  take the charge and he might have  altered the shot three on one davis love  lebron  finish it  anthony davis in the middle of the break  gets to lavish this  how about a.d  the middle man as stu said the point  guard was a point guard in high school i  know he was  sprouted  up to a d from lebron and then lebron  saves it blindly and they dodge a bullet  because they missed the shot the lakers  go down and get bucket  [Music]  you